like hundreds of years ago.
Strange, all right.
It's not its shape.
Yes, well, to the end of the Middle Ages,
that was all we knew about our world.
Because to go into the interior,
there was one gigantic obstacle.
They were scared to death.
The unknown, the imaginary.
Wouldn't have been.
Unknown, come on.
Back then, they had the things to fear
besides the little mouse.
There's a ship sailing for Africa.
They're looking for men.
Oh, I look crazy.
Know what they got in store?
There's some sailors who saw a sea serpent
over a mile long, swallowing down a ship.
Unicorns ram ships with their horn.
Sun is so low it boils the ocean it darkens and burns people's skin.
At the far limit, the ocean falls into a pit.
And on the other side, walk upside down.
It never come back.
Now, here's Portugal.
A small country of about one million inhabitants.
It's from here that Prince Henry the Navigator
will organize the discovery of the world.
My son, you cannot be king because you are not the eldest, but you will discover much that is hidden to other men. May it serve you well.
You see, my son, thirty years ago, with God's help, I fought and conquered Castile.
But they're strong and one day might chase out us infidels, and so we must strengthen our supremacy while there is still time.
Yes, father. I'll try to maintain our country as a great sea power.
If we can inflict defeat on the Muslims, we will be champions of the Christian faith, and the Pope will give us his support.
Our objective is to conquer the city of Ceuta, on the coast of Morocco. It's important that we control it.
May the Lord go with you, my son.
It's wheat, and here's rice and salt, pepper, cinnamon, and ginger as well.
Yes, noble one, ginger, and also excellent cinnamon like perfume, and pepper, fresh and in seeds.
These are all rare products of the Orient.
How did you get them?
In Portugal, they're worth gold.
From the Senegal River, Oconet, sir.
There is also gold there.
Every three months, a caravan leaves.
It crosses mountains, a desert, then stops at the river bank.
There we barter silently.
Silent bartering?
Oh, yes, sir.
We bring our salt, our beautiful coral jewelry, cloth, knives.
Not enough gold.
This, however, is a good deal.
Even though we don't speak their language and they don't speak ours.
Father, now I know. There, in southern Africa, there are unknown lands and gold as well.
Maps are not accurate. See Ptolemy's map? I will group scholars together, construct many a ship.
I will man every ship, and by sea, we will have the riches of the Orient.
You do that. Do just as you say, Henry.
And at Sagres, on the southwestern tip of Portugal, Henry will have a genuine research institute built,
and he'll invite astronomers and map makers and navigators and...
Zarco, you sail to the south.
Steer a course veering from the African coast.
It is said there is a magnificent green island there.
Yes, Royal Highness, I will follow your orders.
You, Pedro, will set a course sailing right along the coast.
Once you have passed Cape Bohador, you will then...
Cape Bohador, Your Highness, that is impossible.
Because it's the end of the world, it is the unknown, it will mean death.
Look here, Pedro, Cape Bohador is no more distant than England is.
What are you afraid of?
I will try.
This barge can carry 40 men and their provisions, and the square mainsail, eh?
It catches the wind for very long voyages.
A square sail and a backing wind's good, but with my triangular one, it's possible to sail against the wind, and who sails?
But your sight, Rudder, unbalances the ship.
The ship is leaning a gust of wind, and it's sure to turn over.
Gail, what's to your boat? What happens to you while I...
Not especially complicated, Prince.
Sailor, I've navigated on many a sea and many a ship.
And what do you suggest?
What I suggest is combining the advantages of the two.
How do we do that?
Well, the rudder at the back.
It's much more stable than a side rudder.
Three masts to increase sail surface.
A narrow hull to cut through the water.
A minimum draft for shallow water.
That's what I suggest.
The rudder was my idea.
But the top sail, that's mine.
The bigger mast, that's mine.
The triangular sail is mine.
The important thing is uniting ideas, gentlemen.
And what's the name of this new creation?
It's a caravel.
Enough of your bickering.
Go and build one of these caravels as he designed it.
And be quick!
Yes, your highness. We humbly obey you, your highness.
But it will never say, your highness.
It's much too small.
Not deep enough in the water.
It'll capsize.
We're within a hundred miles of Cape O'Hador.
The end of the known world will all be dead.
Do we sail on, Captain?
Observe, the wind's turning. The ocean eats agitated.
The water's cold, Captain.
I'm in command here.
I say the sea's rough.
Turn around now. We return to Portugal.
Wish to see me, Prince Henry.
Yehuda, yes, I did.
Look, here is the well-known Catalan Atlas drawn by your father.
Tell me, why is it that such eminent people as you have left Spain?
We were chased out, your highness.
All the Jews were chased from Spain.
You're right. I forgot.
Here you are welcome.
Look, will you help me bring your father's maps up to date?
You will be my chief cartographer.
Oh, yes, I certainly will.
I too can help you, old prince.
My name is Sebastian, famous cartographer of Genoa.
I know all the oceans and all the coastlines.
We'll see, Sebastian, but watch it.
All that we do here is totally secret, under pain of death, understand?
Well, Jehuda, come with me.
That's why we must have a maximum of information
and of observations that are very precise.
You'll note exact positions of each hill and village, and even the trees.
Every detail will be of help to our navigators.
You see, if I don't force them to widen our knowledge, then it won't be done, I assure you.
Because there isn't one sea captain who'll go anywhere if there's no profit for him.
Under Henry's energetic supervision, the center at Sagres is beginning to show results.
At the shipyard, caravels are even more improved, made faster and faster,
and Madeira will be colonized in 1420,
and the Azores in 1427.
Ah, here's the brave explorer returned from Cape Bochador.
Highness Captain Dominguez has returned at last.
Cape Bochador, did you sail around it?
At risk to my life, and because of my devotion to your highness,
I approached it to within a few leaves.
Did you sail around it?
I was able to learn, risking my life, that the cape is not navigable.
Imagine water boiling us in a cauldron.
Suddenly, a giant dragon rose up fire, shooting from its mouth.
I sailed in closer despite the terrible heat and saw the ocean falling into a bottomless pit.
Your Highness, there can be no doubt, it's the end of the habitable world.
There's no going beyond that, Kate Bojado.
Yes, Giles.
Your Highness, let me go.
Now I'm a good sailor. All I need is a caravel, Your Highness.
Granted.
And Sebastian knows the region very well. He will go with you.
Dominguez will be a lowly deckhead.
Me, a lowly deckhand, what a revolting insult.
Just wait.
We will have the last word yet.
You will see.
This is threatened.
Henry of Portugal is trying to sail around the African continent to find a route to the Orient.
He has built fast ships, caravels.
Venice's wealth comes from our trade with the Orient.
If he finds a new sea route, we're ruined.
Well, Prince Henry really finds such a route.
He will, according to our spy who's there at Sagres.
We must do everything we can to stop him.
Everything?
Yes.
We'll be rewarded.
It's the Canary Islands, so soon we'll see Cape Bohador.
Cape Bohador?
Expedition.
I trust you, Captain.
You're in whose pay?
A steal?
So it's Venice, then.
And the maps. You're the ones who stole them.
No, Prince Henry, you could say we only borrowed them, we brought them back.
You know how we punish traitors here.
Take them away!
I took none of all that I saw.
No sign of any men or animals.
A coast completely deserted.
Here are a few palm trees, they're a rocky outcrop.
No monsters boiling sea, eh?
Nothing like that.
Sea is calm, beach is quiet, the water's quite shallow.
And what now?
I begin again.
Either I go around Cape Bojador and return, or I try and never return.
Enthusiasm of youth, it's touching.
Just setting off without knowing what dangers await.
I have a little object that might come in handy.
Simple and quite ingenious.
When the ship sways, the compass remains horizontal.
No, it's a simple idea, nothing much.
Stars on the horizon.
We're on the same latitude now as Cape Bohador.
Fall ahead south.
The wind is good.
A hill lies to the west and a clump of useful landmarks.
Shoals ahead, heading south-southeast.
We'll sail away from the coast.
You're not gonna turn around?
Not before we've sailed around that cursed cape.
Captain!
We've reached our objective.
But it's, it's, it's, it's the mo, the mo, the mo, the mo, the mo, mo.
The mo, mo?
The moment we die, the end of the world.
Look up ahead, Pinto.
That is Cape Bohador. Land like hundreds you've seen.
But the fire dragon, it's the end of the world.
Not at all, Pinto. It can't be the end of the world.
Rather, the beginning of a new world.
Mary, Mary, Mary, we'll bring it to Prince Henry as true testimony of our conquest.
And so you did sail around Cape Bohador, the Cape of Fear.
Now, the route to the Orient is ours.
My opinion, just by sailing a little farther down, we now have details concerning the coast of Cape Bohador.
It's time we explored inland to find out what the land is like. We're going to need horses.
Test the anchor!
What do they want?
I see. He thinks that we're painted white.
Thought they were all painted black.
It sure is a crazy world.
We might take them back with us and sell them as slaves. We could get rich.
For sale, African couple in good health, obedient, excellent workers,
a real bargain, yours for only three croissados.
Believe me, it's rare merchandise coming direct from Africa.
Who will buy them? Who?
So it was the Portuguese who began the slave trade?
Yes, unfortunately, the slave trade was widespread throughout Africa.
You remember I told you.
It was a source of income for African kings.
Drip deep slave for one horse?
It's a deal.
And Henry, what was his opinion on this traffic?
Well, Henry did discourage it. He opposed it, but...
Look here, we're not making discoveries to put men into slavery, but to open the world to our merchant fleet.
Yes, surely, but slavery already exists, Your Highness. It's not us Portuguese who invented it.
And we have a great need for manual laborers. Anyway, the church hasn't yet decided whether these creatures are human,
if they truly are creatures to whom God has given a soul.
If they have one, we'll ask for a higher price, eh?
And so the slave trade grew and prospered.
In any case, the work of the Sagres Center was bearing fruit.
Henry's navigators would sail farther and farther.
Yes, they will discover new lands.
1447, Guinea.
1448, construction of Fort Argan in the north of Senegal.
1455, exploration of the Gambia.
Thank you, Dynastias, for your courage on your expeditions.
Thanks to you all, my friends, for your devotion to our cause.
If there is still much work to do, you must sail around Africa, expand our known world.
You must dedicate yourselves to this task.
Future.
Just as I explained it.
Yes, let me take your son, Bartholomew.
He'll be like a son to me.
I'll teach him all my knowledge.
You see, when a ship crosses the equator, the pole star drops out of sight, eh?
You have to know how to calculate position by using the sun.
I have an excellent work in Hebrew that explains it very well.
In 1481, young John II was crowned King of Portugal.
Time to leave on the great voyage, Bartholomew.
We must continue the work of Henry, whom we honor.
You have two ships, two fine caravels, and a larger ship for provisions.
But most valuable, you will have a map with complete details concerning Africa and the Indian Ocean.
Once again, the work of our late lamented Henry.
Fearing it's a storm! Careful! The ice will snap! Bring down the sails!
Let's use this calm to move up to the east.
Another 10 days and still nothing. I'm sure that we've sailed around Africa.
Set a course to the north.
Look again.
Around Africa and opened the route to the Orient.
Look.
1892, hmm?
Columbus reaches the Americas.
1499, Vasco de Gama sails to Calcutta in India.
1500, Cabral discovers Brazil.
1419, Magellan attempts to sail around the world.
And all of it began when, braving ignorance and superstition,
the young Prince Henry the Navigator,
Founded at Sagres in Portugal, a research center that in a very real sense led to the discovery of our world.